(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Romain Lacombe
is a man on a mission.
- Air pollution is an environmental issue,
but most of all it's a health crisis.
- [Narrator] More than five
million people die every year
from pollution-related illnesses.
Romain wants to change that.
He has designed a system to help humans
learn more about the air they breathe
and he did it in the most
unconventional way imaginable,
using pigeons wearing tiny backpacks.
- I will never look at pigeons
ever again like I did before.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] London, like
many cities, has a problem,
pollution.
It's so bad here it kills
nearly 10,000 citizens a year.
- The problem about the
weather and pollution
is they interact together
and sometimes create episodes
of very high pollution.
- [Narrator] London weather
is notoriously fickle
and pollution levels
change with the weather.
Rains wash up pollutants
and winds sweep them away.
Romain wanted to make
the invisible, visible.
To do that, he found a
way for people to know
when the air is particularly toxic.
Enter the Pigeon Air Patrol.
(upbeat music)
- [Romain] The Pigeon Air Patrol
was this brilliant, crazy idea
to fly a flock of pigeons
over the city of London
with tiny little backpacks
to measure air pollution.
- [Narrator] Romain outfitted
a flock of ten birds
to fly around London to monitor
air quality in real time.
(upbeat music)
(pigeons cooing)
They wore special backpacks
equipped with sensors
to measure pollutants like
ozone and nitrogen dioxide,
and they weren't just ordinary birds,
they were highly trained racing pigeons.
- [Romain] We worked with
Brian, expert pigeon fancier
who's been very widely
recognized in that field.
These are professional pigeons.
They race,
they know how to always home
back to their home base.
We had an entire patrol of pigeons,
Coco, Norbert, Julius ...
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] When the
pigeons took the to sky,
the data they collected
was instantly accessible
to anyone on the ground.
Citizens could tweet the Pigeon Air Patrol
and the nearest backpack sensor
would respond with readings
from low to extreme.
- Thanks to this, people tuned in
to know when's a good time to go running
and when you can bike without
worrying about pollution,
or when you should really take extra care
about the air you breathe.
The Pigeon Air Patrol was
just a starting point,
so of course the Pigeon Air Patrol
was not fixing pollution in London,
but by bringing attention from
everyone about this topic,
we make it easier for
citizens to demand change.
And so we make it easier
for everyone involved
to say there's an issue there.
We should recognize it,
we should address it,
and then we can fix it.
(upbeat music)